okay it's uh it's going to be starting
soon okay
dear weed
no
i think i left it at your house [ __ ]
oh my god i have to do a sober one
we'll do some crown royal
yeah you want to bust it out
i'm good i'm not
i'll drink it i'll drink it yeah pour it
up really yeah okay [ __ ] it yeah are you
gonna drink it oh yeah three you want to
drink i'm not no i don't drink that okay
three i'm good three out of four
it's a little out of focus on the bottom
oh gosh shiva
you're right in front of the camera
oh it already started
yeah
[Laughter]
it says what up pocs
hey oh wow yeah this is a poc this is a
poc podcast a pocket cast a park the
pack two pucks and
one
cup
two packs of two box one cup
[Laughter]
very nice
we got some of austin's finest blaring
outside
stomping on some homeless guy's head
hopefully yeah hopefully
you know what i you know what i don't
like out in texas
that every like
every like emergency vehicle here uses
the cop lights
you mean like you're like emts yeah emcs
have cop lights yeah isos is like the
red and blue yeah like the emts at least
where i grew up they were they they were
like orange and white like they had
different lights yeah but here like the
road workers like the this
jesus they give it out to anyone they
deputize them yeah the city workers they
have the cop lights it's very confusing
it's like why i guess they're just
there's still the fear of god in you
where'd you where did you live
i live in california oh okay they all
have different lights fire truck lights
are different than ambulance lights or
different cop lights are different than
like city worker lights but here that
was liberal to me
people who put like the cones out to
block off the highway they have complex
and they're not cops and mesquite
there's a there's actual people that
that uh turn their car decorate their
car exactly how their their police do it
but they have to put uh
citizen arrest or like citizen police oh
interesting something like that but they
actually decorate their car to look like
a cop car i think they have cop lights
because all of them also don't like
black people that's impossible yeah but
yeah i don't know
it's just it's just so weird how do i
patrol like there's cops that i've seen
that don't even have like
you have to like be next to it to see
that it's police oh yeah well they have
those like chargers now that are like
all blacked out they're supposed to
they're supposed to be like undercover
cops on the road right yeah that's their
whole that's the whole energy the
trickery
yeah it's all about right here i don't
like it it's weird yes power authority
yeah it is it's their way of reminding
you like you know don't worry on your
toes don't worry guy who moved from a
liberal place your our foots are on your
neck too yeah all right that's like you
ain't they know they're any less foot on
your neck wait i think it's more
especially you well especially
yeah who's that but
you funded them
do you uh you comfortable you want a
longer mic arm because that my arm is
pretty long and it's just going that
this is
you can also scoot up your arm chair
but uh
yeah
we uh we had a party at my place last
night we did the kill tony then we did
the creek
um
one night last night all right i had a
blood that was crazy you met the
australian jews yeah australians yeah
and you were enjoyed their trickery and
their i didn't any fascinating the
amount of effort they put in their
trickery
i mean they're cunning why you gotta
explain this trickery that that's the
thing was i walked in they were really
nice people they introduced themselves
and and then you know i was tripping
mushrooms during kill tony though i was
like bad idea but by the time i got to
han's party it was it was coming down a
little bit they were talking and somehow
i brought up the the word porn and this
guy looked at me was like what is that
i was like how you [ __ ] with me bro
you [ __ ] with me and he like played
into it his friends they huddled up
played into it also they were like oh
they took they took like a rift time out
to be like they're talking on the same
board there was more than two words
like is he talking about like
like cinema photos or like like no
pornography like they they all clicked
up on me yeah but you spent like an hour
talking to him too man it's just about
the moment he was he was very believable
he got me for some reason and then i
even like brought in other comments i
left
by the time i got outside one of his
friends like oh man he was googling some
[ __ ] on my phone so i went inside to see
if he still played he was still on and i
was like what stick horse thing [ __ ]
dirty [ __ ] i mean stick horses is the
form of uh porn i guess i never i've
never
heard of it i don't know what kind of
jews they were but they had like the
locks but then they had an australian
accent they looked and had an australian
accent that like orthodox or something
yeah
but we're talking a lot of [ __ ] after
that but they were really cool and
but i i just thought that was a real
[ __ ] up game for playing with people
you know
like just like for fun i mean maybe they
can i mean
you're [ __ ] with people at a party
that's fun maybe yes i'm saying that it
was it was all good they're both [ __ ]
with each other but the the link and
they think
the links that he went to yeah
yeah the people people commit to the bit
it's dude people come more cool for the
bit
you ever watched the prestige the
prestigious yeah yeah do you remember
there was that magician whose entire
life yeah he lived with the fish bowl
yeah yeah on in his legs so it just
looked like he always wanted [ __ ]
yeah you'd have to be strong as an ox to
do this
that's the point michael caine yeah
but yeah dude people commit to the bit
right like you know and those those
that's
important that's art that's art part of
it i was a little you know under the
influence too so you know i wasn't
totally
there
you're having fun though yeah i was
having fun i was talking to a lot of og
comics on the patio you know like
patrice and richard and george carl you
know how they're all like painted yeah
yeah their eyes and their facial
expression to me at the time was like me
telling them that i was on shrooms and
they were making those faces to me
that's pretty funny it was pretty epic
it was annoying we spoke to the gods on
mountain everyone had the perfect face
patrice was like dude [ __ ] with me
[ __ ] idiot you know you spoke to them
they're alive in our heads they're never
dead
you know like
it was perfect it was like you know it
was pretty epic
i peaked
someone says hans one more button off
please
do it you gotta get the people what they
want to give them these fans are so
rabid yeah
they're gonna do it though
i think you should tease them and put up
a button button up
[ __ ] what they misbehave
how can you see that promise from where
you are like they're my glasses
you want me to put it up on the tv
can you do that yeah
that was pretty awesome that's so that's
so
involved
yeah i mean
we can read it and [ __ ] people i mean
that would be pretty cool
well yeah man so australian jews uh i
understand why people hate jews now
really it took you this long yeah i
never knew i never knew that i never
knew and and australia and australia and
then they admitted like they said we lie
that's what we do i'm like well did the
holocaust really happen
that's where you took it no yeah
dude yeah
it's so interesting have you never
met like hung out with jews beforehand
all right
i've been i don't say like oh if you
hung out and hang out with us
i mean uh a couple girls guys but it's
like it's like when you hang out with
any race it's like like oh heavy you're
like okay that's what it is about this
race that i don't like right yeah right
i was like you finally get it i was like
have you never had friends but i think
in texas if someone's gonna lie to you
for no reason at all
it's mostly like coming off like with
just negativity you know but but like
being friendly and just [ __ ] lying to
someone
yeah yeah yeah
we shoot the [ __ ] right right yeah [ __ ]
but uh literally i didn't want to like
ruin his life and teach this guy what
porn was
i didn't want like i felt that you just
failed on porn after like two minutes
been like you're done and then left him
alone and then like you know
and he would have been like i'm trying
to do an australian oy v i don't know
how to i can pull that off
off camera where's your noise
right now we're trying to watch hans
locate the hdmi plug on the back of the
series
it's not conveniently located well it's
all right whatever you're not that you
don't have to do you don't have to some
of those
rip it out
let's rip out the vulcan tv while we're
here
not on that side no
it's like on the back
i want
this whatever we don't need to see the
comments i i feel like the comments are
mostly just talking to themselves anyway
yeah they're generally i mean i wouldn't
say trolling just having their own
separate conversation
well
we gave it a shot
good job man good id work there
well you know
we had a party
riley and i had a falling out
would you
republic at the party yeah it was very
awkward it was very it was very very
awkward
it was very awkward
it's like a real deal would you describe
you describe it as a falling out
yeah i mean
he swore at me i'd write a text today i
mean people swear to you though
yeah you're right you try to punch
another dude in front of his girl to see
more like yeah
you know that's where you're working
when i felt like you were [ __ ] him in
front of his girlfriend no no no riley
was trying to point my boy hans man okay
in front of hans's girl yeah no i'm
freddie no from him
okay okay i'm still gonna be okay now i
got it all right he was like uh
is there anything not to say
yeah like he wanted me to he was like
very kindergarten very liberal
montessori type of
way to talk to people
well
what okay so you gotta you gotta explain
what like what
started this confrontation at this party
so christy and i used to be friends and
i haven't been talking to her and i've
been kind of giving her the cold
shoulder and then we're at the party and
like riley coming to the podcast
tomorrow she's like how dare you invite
him and not me it's like it's just a
podcast we do together it's
doesn't really involve you i don't mean
to exclude you and then she was like you
used to hang out with me and i was like
yeah i was trying to [ __ ] you
[Music]
okay well you did say that to your
friend's girlfriend
did you say that or you're like
i hung out well she brought it up
right now it's honest it's honestly i'm
trying to have sex with you it's not
like that's a lie okay and then you said
i don't want to have sex with you and so
we're not hanging out anymore she's like
that's sexist you only like me from my
vagina i was like
well you never got to experience the
vaginas that's not yeah i can be correct
yeah so i
would love to do vagina stuff with you
and if you can i don't want to be around
something that's going to be frustrating
i'm sorry but i don't want to hang out
with you yeah
it's fair
yeah
that's really honest
you kind of treat her like an equal
there uh that's yeah that's what's
another man that i would want to [ __ ]
oh yeah
but uh yeah it got weird for me to watch
this [ __ ] go down
was it like in the middle of the whole
party like it was in the middle of the
patio in the middle of the circle well
it kept changing locations actually
this is like a saga yeah yeah oh whoa
so the first act was in the kitchen and
then yeah second act it's just selfish
to be like i want to air my petty
grievances at the expense of everyone's
attention it's like
this it's like uh everyone has to listen
to us now but it's like you know
whatever it's like you know she's like
she wants to do that you know like she
wants to like make a scene and it's like
more interesting than whatever [ __ ]
we could talk about anyways i guess
right we're talking about it now
the drama drama i find that like any
anytime you're in a green room
drama talk eventually starts to take
over yeah yeah yeah that's uh it's it's
part of the fun of being in a green room
i'll do this oh yeah
i also was gonna say he you they asked
for him to apologize and you were nice
enough to do it and then
was telling them like to apologize he
was like for what she's not going to
accept my apology and this is exactly
what happened yeah she's like i don't
accept your apology because i've given
you so much emotionally spiritually
financially and you haven't done
anything for me back
that's a red flag thing to say i know
are you keeping a ledger on everything
good thing i've never done for me yeah
energetically that's no currency
energetic yeah that's a that's pretty
[ __ ]
yeah she's
she's a firecracker she's a crazy fun
person to be around but i wouldn't want
to
see that every day
it's a lot
emotionally
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know i probably shouldn't
be talking about it on the podcast but
you started with it
i never stopped talking about i never
was like what happened
yeah but that is what's gonna happen in
a green room podcast isn't it
feel the energy of the place
oh yeah
but yeah i mean that happened last night
that's fun
i like having the parties you know it's
like instead of just going home alone
it's like we can bring what we had at
the open mic at the shows back to the
place and have a place where people hang
out and
yeah i wanted to get a regular thing how
many people were were there like 30.
that's a fair amount and it's pretty
much just all comics you had no sickness
like five australian jews too before we
had a party the day before at home
that's okay so hans is hans you're in
party mode right now yeah i mean once we
get a good hang going we can monetize we
can film it and create content
eventually he wants enough players to
play katana at the end of the rest of
the woods yeah
yeah the party kind of gets in the way
of katan because they're getting so late
what continuity is supposed to go to
katan but the
time to play right yeah so it's like
that's hard and 30 people continue
players he needs like five players i
think
yeah
the more the merrier and austin katan
league is that where you're trying to
start
that'd be nice
that's the ultimate goal of the
of the podcast yeah okay nice
i haven't think about stuff like some
sort of board game league like an austin
code names league or something like that
i think that'd be a lot of fun
[Music]
yeah austin code name on katan
no no code names is another board game
that is like fire if you've never played
it it's my favorite it's i'm sorry hanzo
to replace katan for me katana was my
number one until until i started playing
code names i was like oh this this is
like how do you play
all right next time we play i'll invent
you
is it like a board game yeah it's a
board game it's a word association game
oh it's like improv no no no no no no
not at all no i'm just that's dragging
yeah don't sully
yeah yeah
it's hard to explain it's like way
simpler than that it's just a regular
board game
but yeah it's yeah i'm assuming there's
some kind of code name right so
basically there's a board full of words
and there's two teams and some of the
words belong to the blue team and some
of the words belong to the red team
so
there's a clue giver that knows which
words are your team's words and you have
to give
one word clues to try to get them
because your words that's pretty but
it's more like teams
that's what makes it crazy fun okay is
that you you work together and like
some of the games get super intense and
kind of work last minute come back
comics working together never
you know what this word means or why
would you pick this word are you [ __ ]
it yeah dude it gets it gets real tense
yeah nice real tense
i'm i'll probably lose that game like i
don't even have any words no you've been
how you don't
play with
i mean i live with like
david cenafani yeah and oh yeah our
galster our neighbors are like jeffrey
douglas and sean riley and then
all the time yeah nice and then phil and
ally you guys have your own crew your
own click
well yeah it's a little board game click
yeah
for sure
yeah
bored
people playing board games
that was really well thought out
i was
killing it yeah thanks guys
open for joe rogan
oh yeah
um but yeah i think it's fun it's like
an excuse to socialize and a lot of
people like i'm better than board games
but who's really better than anything
who yeah also better than like the most
fun things board games are like it's fun
it's like a way to be competitive and
social at the same time so you got to
use your imagination mm-hmm
i like risk i don't know it's old school
what's going on now
i feel like
this could be more in your face
wow i mean i'm i feel like i'm doing a
good job of leaning
you're doing a horrible job at leaning
yeah yeah
that is that is definitely way more in
my face
it's like a diorama
an intricate set piece
this is an intricate set piece but now
it's like too little on you though
you are the i mean hans you are the main
focus of this right yeah totally
um hopefully not
but uh yeah this is good uh we got the
orange world versus the white world
oh you guys are kind of backlit can you
like close the curtain more on that side
that might help yeah
but yeah what do you think oh wow
interesting
what do you think about uh you know
cancer culture
do you think about cancer culture
actually look so good i want to let
hassan know who jd poe is mm-hmm
he says there's a comic from dallas bro
i guess had a mental break okay psycho
or something okay
uh lost his job
uh started threatening people on ig live
like women comics starting to shoot them
up or what jesus so he ended up uh sperm
and he ended up uh going to uh uh
probably about the asylum right right so
they let him out and they do house
checks on them okay and uh apparently he
he was tired about of the
the hospital checking on him or police
checking out wellness training and he
[ __ ]
came to austin okay and he's been out
here with his briefcase
like getting bad like he got kicked out
of shakespeare's he's banned from the
creek he's banned from here yeah and
he's just walked in on christina p or
like he's doing pretty bad apparently
rebecca threw a drink at him or
something because he was being an ass he
threw her he threw his hat at her or
some [ __ ] so he got banned but he was
walking the streets last night
like like
yeah some chasing him yeah or
confronting him chasing comics in front
of cricket and cave saying [ __ ]
comedians like
literally lost his mind oh well that's
scary that's yeah he's out here lurking
yeah that's scary feel very bad for him
yeah it's not yeah it's not good oh yeah
he was he was an [ __ ] before all that
crazy [ __ ] happened but it's also true
no that is also true any other crazy
people you want to give a shout out
okay i'm letting everybody know to look
out for this guy in austin i mean he he
look out yeah
he's like he got motive to do some crazy
[ __ ] yeah i mean that's the number one
thing does he talk about wanting to
shoot places up
um i think dude i think he's on drugs
okay he's on
that makes you feel a lot better because
yeah one thing we learned in mass
shooter training is that the people who
do it
always talk about it so if he's talking
about it then i'd be afraid yeah a
little more afraid not just a regular
crazy guy i'll be like well that's just
par for the course for comedy yeah
yeah
yeah yeah we gotta
i mean i think
shootings are like a young man's game i
think once you're an open miker you're
like uh
i hate myself more than anything really
um
or you at least have some kind of event
yeah to prevent yourself from you know
you can go yell at a crowd yeah
necessarily you kind of figure a [ __ ]
out as adults yeah but wasn't las vegas
an old man yeah that's yeah
that's true
with the gambling problem well there's
always the rodney dangerfield of oh
yeah
it's never too late
you can get started at any age
there's always hope hopefully this
doesn't get demonetized like the last
one we did we got last one got
demonetized yeah why i don't know
probably because we said that it makes
sense that people want to shoot up at
school
nice oh did we yeah
man
well speaking of cancel culture
no i mean i mean
when you ask that what do you mean by
council culture what do you think about
it like what do you think about it i
think it's generally
a good force of like hey think about
what you're saying and like how it
impacts people because we come from a
culture of conquest and
you know exploitation and it's just like
we have a lot of fixing to do and a lot
of people don't want to fix fix their
[ __ ] right away but i think overall it's
slow to like
figure it out i think just
it's like think about it don't say the
most worst thing try to have good takes
and like not have like
you know say horrible things about other
people or try to get a reaction or
something like just play that [ __ ]
game like those australian jews
no it's just like don't uh recognize the
evil in the culture that you come from
and sort of try to work against it
just being like whatever i don't have to
try
who i am is who i am
yeah but i think uh you know they can go
too far i mean they learned how to
engage with people from republicans so
they use their liberal values in a very
republican way yes yes they try to dixie
chick everyone
well yeah well they they try to like
yeah it's very interesting where it's
like i get what you're saying in terms
of like it's oh it's
good for us to challenge whatever sort
of
thing is being taught like told to us or
what we see yeah but then it it then
it's just sort of become like this tool
to be like well let's just silence the
people we don't like yeah they get lazy
with it
if you if you think about this that try
to cancel someone
and then the mob of their supporters
like really go ham on whoever they try
to cancel it's like
yeah like we should be
caring about people [ __ ] this guy he
doesn't yeah nobody and they're like oh
yeah [ __ ] him
the people are just like things like oh
turn that off turn that one off turn
this one on and so on it's not like that
you can't just turn people off yeah like
you gotta be like more you know
nurturing and more like a montessori
school
and they're not they're like public
education detention
yeah that's not like a systematic issue
yeah it's the worst mix of liberal and
conservative but yeah you should have
more compassion and like you know
instead of having a criminal justice
system that's all about you know
punishment you should have one like
norway
and you should be like come into the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
jail cell you'll have a guitar
yeah it is it is weird that a jail is
just what the [ __ ] a jail is just uh
uh
there's nothing to do
yeah that doesn't seem like it would be
any helpful and like if you want to
management yeah if you but like it's
like you can you definitely can turn a
lot of these people into productive
members of society
yeah they put them in there besides like
yeah instead of making them worse
instead of and then well then i mean
basically what now now this private
system is like this is pretty much just
slavery again right yeah that's the
whole point there's people there's a
picture of black people holding hoes and
a white dude on a horse like the prison
guard and it's like
that's like yeah yeah yeah plantation
it's just yeah but now it's
time
yeah yeah
yeah and louisiana has like the highest
rate of that [ __ ] and it's just like
just [ __ ] badass [ __ ] put him in
jail and throw away the key it's like
not a great way to do it but
um yeah have you ever been to jail yeah
i've been in jail i shoplifted from a
target when i was in college where i'm
not like shooting are you trying to
target jail or like they're watching me
so i'm saying like what are you doing
what are you trying like a mouse and
like bowls and like food and wow that's
a lot but i was just trying how would
you try to take it in my backpack okay
if they catch you immediately or do they
let you steal it people
until you've stolen enough that's
considered like a felony or misdemeanor
and then they get you so they you still
go back to the same target it's in
atlanta
do you like visiting that target when
you're in atlanta so just
a little nostalgic when was last time
you're in that target
that was a lot i haven't been back how
long ago was that that was in college
i'm 33 now so that's like 12 years ago
oh you could totally walk back into that
yeah they won't notice yeah they don't
have a picture on the wall you should
you should you should prove to yourself
that you can steal all that stuff now
and go back and just do that
like before you walked out they're like
hey yeah it was a police officer because
they saw me with a little razor blade
slicing things up and went out all the
time
i had a little little uh drawstring bag
in the front so i could drop things
in oh you had it in the front yeah how
much stuff did you steal before you got
caught
like three thousand dollars worth of
stuff
yeah you thought you were pretty good
too it was like my life yeah yeah i'm
like this is what i'm gonna get good at
because it didn't make any sense for me
to be a part of the system
okay
okay why did it make no sense for you to
be a part of the system because it's a
rigged game uh because it's not fair so
let's just cheat it it doesn't matter
right but then i realized that's the
stupidest way to
cheat
what ambush your your record basically
physically yeah it's not not the best
physically you got to do it through
other like more intelligently white
collar crimes or like become a comedian
yeah yeah it's a good this is a great
way to keep this yeah dude yeah most
people are a lot of people are at work
right now yeah being a gear and we're
like
so when they took care of the car so
they took you to jail right yeah and
then like did you have like a cellmate
or something
they put me in
general sort of like general population
yeah oh you had a jumpsuit no no we're
not wearing our clothes
you were there for like a day yeah like
12 hours almost yeah and then they were
like pre-trial
diversion or whatever like don't let
white kids stay in jail too long dot-com
act
whatever
i think that's what they call it
actually but yeah
there was a misdemeanor this is my first
time so they let me out earlier um
did you have to go to and that was it
yeah that was it i hired a lawyer for
like a thousand bucks mm-hmm i
jason sheffield the same lawyer that
defended george mcmichaels
in the one where they shot ahmad arbury
that was my lawyer
[Music]
books no
way
wait so do you recommend him
yeah
well every time it's customer service
or customer or whatever the volunteer
yeah
community service as long as it's a
misdemeanor
and not a felony apparently yeah
jason sheffield if you [ __ ] up and you
need to not pay the price of your crimes
commercial jesus yeah yeah they lost
yeah it was a pretty public class so but
now we know he's one and one in the
public
yeah he's the one he's gonna you know he
has a pretty big win on his side he got
hans kim on i didn't do
all i had to do was community service
and i even forged that
nicely i got the letter you learned in
the church
i did like 20 hours i was supposed to do
40 i was like i did 40. sign it mm-hmm
well
yeah i mean i don't respect it i mean i
did
feel bad because this target you know
like why do you feel better yeah why do
you just i didn't
oh i don't know
that's the last people you feel bad
about target
[ __ ] that dog with that target on his
eye
but yeah i mean
uh i think riley's a great guy because
he likes
he's so honest and genuine but he's like
it's like you know either he's on and
he's like good or he's like you know
it's he's hanging out with someone
[ __ ] up and
they're telling that's that's a broad
way to see it man
you're giving him a chance
to to make you're actually giving him a
chance to apologize
and you'll probably accept this apology
but it's paul yeah but i mean in front
of like me like watching that i try to
make a joke like how does he was like uh
we love you or she loves you you should
you should apologize like how does he
love her if he loves me like just trying
to ease the thing but he was staring him
down bro like i'm in a pan
damn but also like you should like
you shouldn't be obligated to hang out
with people you don't want to hang out
with yeah yeah or whatever you want to
work with that's absolutely for whatever
reason yeah even if it was
your best your best friend's girlfriend
yeah and i said i would try to hang out
with her it's not like i said i wouldn't
i was like okay i admit that i wasn't
hanging out with you i'll try to hang
out with you now and they're like no
i want you to apologize bend the knee
yeah yeah but that's very that's very
cancer culturally to expect the apology
and then not accept it yeah
that's a very like oh
the apology just means guilt it doesn't
mean
there's like no
road to redemption
when you respect your feelings so much
where it's like that's the end all be
all then it's like this is mercurial
it's not a solid thing to base anything
on like your feelings can change and
even if you get everything you want if
it's too easy your feelings would be
like well that wasn't what i wanted i
wanted some struggle with it so it's
like it's difficult to know what they
want there's no end you're just saying
words hans
no that made sense no no i'm talking
about the apology that that's why they
didn't accept it because they thought he
was just saying it
like that's where it starts
yeah yeah as opposed to dancing it yeah
it's better than not saying it right
yeah
at least i have the [ __ ] you know
desire to say it at all it's on the
record that you apologize that's awesome
[Laughter]
yeah i mean it's petty
petty drama but you know
it's good that we can talk about it
yeah he's got the joe rogan show coming
up tonight and we're in the green room
for it
okay all right we're gonna have to clean
up and get the [ __ ] out of here soon
what's up what time is the first show
or is this only one show yeah one show
okay
but are you on it this week yeah yeah so
yeah i mean you're already here you know
so yeah hopefully they'll come in and
sponge [ __ ]
but yeah this is a pain in the ass to
set up i i'm gonna get [ __ ] so we can
all have headphones
because i didn't have the cable but yeah
something up on your amazon list
yeah i ordered it it comes in tomorrow
maybe uh maybe an actual producer so you
don't have to do everything
well i like the thing of not having a
producer because that's just one extra
person who's like knows he doesn't
belong there but he's just doing it
because
whatever right he likes me or right
right right right
it's just who wants to help out but
really that's not really helping we're
just sitting here yeah i get that
if this is just us then it sucks because
of us and not anyone else like there's
no [ __ ]
i get that
but last week was fun because william
was here and uh
riley was here and riley was just like
really into himself and then
william was just like freaking out over
it
but how long are you guys in town for
uh tomorrow we leave back to dallas how
long were you guys we're here since
saturday saturday okay what like what
show were you just doing like a run of
shows
yeah we need peckerheads and and
filthy how was your house it was nice
for like 50 plus that was a
yeah the motorcycle was kind of like
oh because it was motorcycle week yeah
or whatever yeah yeah you can hear their
battery outside
and it was just it's just loud right
yeah yeah
and then playing music
i went up to
um
and then uh yeah
that was fun yeah then i was like most
comedy clubs are in basements for this
reason
because if you're up then everything can
hit you but if you're down right then
you're surrounded
then you can create a world easier
you're not like oh look there's a
motorcycle out there there's a woman
yelling over there it's just like you
and this person's voice where is
peckerheads
right down the street oh it's like a
block away yeah yeah there is this like
weird rush to do like all these shows on
and around six then it's like there's i
feel like there's a lot i was doing the
green j yeah and that was the same thing
yeah i feel like there's just a lot of
there's still a lot of untapped markets
in austin i think there's like no
there's like two shows south of the
river
it's like nothing south of the river and
uh
so much foot traffic here though it's
like why wouldn't you try to have it
on downtown you need a big parking lot
well that's what i feel like about what
west village there was a lot of foot
traffic in westfield there was a couple
of little clubs there maybe do something
new york yeah new york yeah yeah well
yeah
but like yeah i mean i i get the i get
the want to do that but like eventually
rogan's club is gonna be down here right
and that's gonna you know there's
because of that there's gonna be a lot
of
comedy on sixth street anyway yeah so if
you could just like the domain is pat
always popping
no shows up there right south of the
river has a ton of people no shows there
they used to have roma room but they
shut it down yeah they should they shut
that down because i was in a bat i don't
think that was in a great location if
i'm being honest but like uh there's a
domain because domain is huge
yeah domain is huge but a lot of people
go there yeah weren't they saying camp
cities
shut down too serious the cap city's
supposed to be there where cap city is
like they're so liberal about it they're
like maybe we'll start but i might take
a mental health day for a week
i don't know they've been rumored to be
opening since february but they keep
pushing these dates back so i'm like no
one has any idea but like there's there
could be shows in all these places yeah
that's what you know but i the reason i
ask is the packet heads the pictures
look good yeah so i thought i was like
oh maybe this was a location that i
didn't know about it
i was pissed because eddie did well the
whole that was really good he was really
close
too much rooms here and awesome yeah
yes
psychedelics in austin i'm microsoft
yeah
but uh yeah if it had sound proof it
would it would have been a great
bit more
production
um yeah i mean this is cool like
the biggest thing is the setup like if
we did this at my house like it wouldn't
require so much setup
because i could do it beforehand right
but the venue school they said they're
going to buy their own equipment so once
they do that maybe we could do it here
more it's pretty easy yeah but the
backdrop is cool
and the whole vibe of being in the green
room yeah you know that's that's such a
it's such a thing yeah
the
you know
like that's such a big part of comedy
there's so much like green room
etiquette
to learn like am i for like a big thing
is like learning when you're allowed to
be in a green room
yeah like that's step one it's like
sometimes you'll walk into a green room
and you'll be like oh this person
shouldn't be here this person shouldn't
be here and they don't really know how
much that hurts them
in the long run yeah they just want to
get there it's not like that though it's
not like mount everest it's not like you
get there and then you can say you did
it it's like you got to stay there and
they have no longevity right
and be allowed like that's the
that's the you know
the level of self-awareness that like if
a young comic doesn't have that where
they don't have that energy of like oh
maybe i shouldn't be in here it's like i
don't think
you're cutting yourself off from a lot
of uh your peers or your elders
and you're not going to get ahead
because like you don't know how to act
on in that environment
but uh yeah i mean it's like really
tricky and really interesting i think
that's where being asian or being
i mean i'm
where you're taught to conform
where you're taught to be respectful and
respect the hierarchy and
you know i think it's really important
and really useful to learn and i think
it's great that like in america it
happens naturally like these people it's
a meritocracy they didn't just i'm not
just respecting them because they're old
so then it means more
whoa hey can you not can you get out of
here
[Laughter]
cake [ __ ] it wasn't drinking talk oh
nice
[ __ ]
i can fix that like but yeah the my oak
green room is cool and like all that and
it's like a mob it's like the mafia
movie it's it is it's very much like oh
am i made man yeah it's that's the way
it should be
yeah
it is weird though it's weird
yeah it's like that no
why is it weird yeah why is it weird i
feel like that's better right than like
everybody being able to walk into
anything no i agree with that right yeah
but it's uh
just hierarchies in general
well
i'm not saying they're necessary but
yeah
they're always yeah i mean i
i mean they they are necessary though
right
yeah
and what yeah what situation is a
hierarchy not necessary that's no
because it's so many people and it's
like somebody's got to control the
direction i get that yeah yeah but i
mean it's not good to have too much
hierarchy because then it's all about
kissing ass you want it to also be about
the comedy mostly right but in the
community
but i think the community here like
people that moved in from l.a
are like you guys know if someone's
funny you treat them like okay that
guy's funny
uh you don't be like uh oh what's the
what's his drama what's his past because
if he's a local if you guys meet
somebody that's a local oh yeah that
guy's good you know it's like funny
matters first before all that political
correctness i think you have to be funny
enough
and then it's politics
it's not fully a meritocracy i don't
think that
is the case i've seen plenty of examples
of bad comics doing very well
in comedy yeah well that's because like
comedy is so hard to figure out if it's
actually
funny or not like because you can think
it's funny but the audience doesn't sure
or versus media oh yeah you don't think
it's funny and the audience loves it
yeah yeah and it's like
i think everything brian holtzman says
it's funny
but there are a lot of people that would
disagree with yeah for sure
that's that's an example of someone
who's very polarizing because if you
don't get it you don't get it yeah
it's it's and maybe eventually you'll
win you over but it's like
you either get it or you don't
yeah
it's like the cowboys either you hate
them or you love them
everything to a cowboy fan comes back to
the cowboys yeah
that's why diversity is so important you
can't just have one type of comedian and
like that's the king and that everyone
else
has to like conform it's like
hey we need every type of comedy because
some people hit really hard with their
audience but not with anyone else and
some people have a general broad appeal
and you need both types you can't just
have one or the other
yeah
so it no matter what it is like if you
do it well then it should be rewarded
even if it's not right
the same as another successful type i i
i will say like
because diversity is one of those words
that people just take and run with and
then they completely miss the point
of what that is you know like diversity
of thought is very important but
diversity just for diversity sake
ends up being more i believe more
hurtful because then you end up plugging
these people in these positions that
like well maybe this is not really for
yeah here's a transgender person that
isn't funny on netflix right advertising
but it's just a transgender person it's
their time where it's like
that's not like an asian person and then
we just got him up there even though
he's not skilled and then he's bombing
in front of a big stage that's even
worse for asians right in the long run
around here yeah right well the the
cream will rise to the top right but
it's like
i think that the key with diversity is
being
open willing to
actually hear the voices versus being
like oh we need an indian guy here so
now we'll listen to indian guys to fit
into this specific box yeah yeah let's
just like chris rock's thing was like
whoa hey can you get out of here we're
trying to do a podcast
but totally rude it's like
it's like chris rock's thing where it's
like there's only so many well maybe
that was kevin hart's where it's like so
many black comedians it's like one two
and then even with indians it feels like
that
where it's like yeah but you know maybe
i think that's maybe a different time
when like it's changing when like
especially when like what dominated what
dominated media was tv and movies
where you know
everything is being held by these
gatekeepers that book these things like
they're like the same six people that if
they have one indian they have one
indian well now it's like
you can just build your own audience
yeah and do that so i don't think i
think when they talk about that i think
that maybe was true for an older time
but like now i don't think that's the
case at all
because now there's so many like people
of color with large platforms true you
know i mean like you're assigned you
remember
like the like whoever was like i guess
the spokesperson for
like the the black comet or like
remember like martin lawrence was like
getting a lot of gigs he had a sitcom
and
and he was on the comedy movies you know
the he was the star of the comedy
blockbuster movies
then it was kevin hart
and then you know like do you think
there's ever going to be another comedy
blockbuster to come out like actually
like
like a comedy blockbuster mode like
that's just like a hangover like a
legendary movie yeah i i would say the
hangover is probably the last
good pure comedy yeah
now like one where there's no message
right there's no like overall because
now now dramatic is the big thing right
yeah yeah is the big thing like it's
funny but also like here's sort of
something yeah here's a yeah learn
something or here's a deep storyline and
it ends with a wedding
yeah and i don't mind that like there
are a lot of good movies but like even
40 year old virgin was like that you
know what i mean like i'm talking about
but that was pretty hangover but like
pure stand up like not piercing pure
comedy no point just to make you laugh
like i think those are done like every
character is all comedians playing
characters like just comedians yeah i
mean comics but that'll be now a comic
funded movie with like you know what i
mean i don't know if there'll be like a
blockbuster big studio like that right
right well big cities can't work with
comics in general because it's such a
powder keg shane gillis proved that
right right yeah
yeah even hollywood wouldn't like touch
dave chappelle like imagine a de
chapelle starring movie comedy but
hollywood i mean
once you get big enough you can do
anything you want i mean chappelle was
in a star wars born right the hollywood
life takes about but
yeah i think we're creatively not in a
very funny place because of world events
and we're not mentally healthy because
we're our empire is dying oh well i mean
our empire is dying that is for sure
so maybe but like we have to wait and
look at this
i heard you don't like roads
[Laughter]
they could build houses on these instead
of
they i was talking about like highways
and suburban sprawl and they were just
like
they weren't understanding it yeah okay
what were you saying
like you shouldn't have suburban sprawl
and highways to connect everything
because that's inefficient you should
build like medium density
uh neighborhoods like they do in europe
and then you can walk around anywhere
you want
uh it's not dangerous you can send your
kids out and it's just a better way to
live it's more efficient you're not
damaging the environment
yeah but yeah they don't but the reason
why that exists in europe is because
they don't have space right
we have a vast amount of land yeah
they've been in their country
you have to have oil to get it around
anywhere and that's not fish yeah that's
true and we had walkable neighborhoods
and america has been around since the
1700s so we had before the car came out
in 1900s it was walkable and then we
created these monstrosities we bought
highways through
cities and destroyed neighborhoods and
created dead zones and now you have to
have a car to get anywhere yeah that's
that is a huge problem with this country
yeah
public public transportation is
non-existent in this country yeah like
outside of new york and chicago new york
was like
like getting around was i mean amazing
to me oh the subway is like it's just
the the when you when you realize like
oh you can live in a situation where you
don't need a car
that's such a freeing thing yeah like
visiting europe and not needing a car
the entire time and even going from
country to country and just using trains
it was like oh this is way better a car
is like
there's heavy it's like you need space
for it dangerous it's dangerous and it's
not on a track you can go anywhere you
want yeah but 99 of people go the same
places so you don't need that much
freedom right yeah and it's uh what's it
called and it's just an extra expense
especially with gas and especially with
like insurance insurance and engine
problems registration yeah fixing it
it's like
it's just well we did that on purpose
because people were moving into the
inner cities and white people were like
this is not this is we can't have this
happening yeah yeah we bailed them out i
mean we bailed out the car dealership
and the levees they built the levees in
white neighborhoods higher than in black
neighborhoods they didn't build them at
all and black neighbor hasn't built the
ones in white neighborhood and that
water
you know if it can't go here then it's
gonna then it was even worse in the
black neighborhoods
because it was so high in the white
neighborhoods
but the the highways you know
the housing is like all
pretty horrible
but you know it's
and that and yeah now and now we're
letting up all these like foreign firms
gobble up these houses and they're just
raising our like i don't understand how
at no point does congress come together
and be like well let's at least let's
make sure american people can buy houses
instead of like
instead of like letting these like
massive corporations just buy these
houses and then sell so there's this old
pla this um
i was going around looking at houses in
austin for a little bit and there was
this place there's this company called
open door
and they just buy up houses and then
they sell them for way over the asking
price
so now they're driving a price in the
neighborhood yeah and then the ones they
don't sell
because they're not a they're not worth
it because they're over their value for
sure right a lot of them are terrible
but they just sit vacant they put them
on bnb or something
and then eventually just brand b and b's
just like to survive
yeah be traveling and moving around so
much that you don't nobody's going to
own a home anymore it feels like that it
feels like a setting i mean there's
there's something like what wasn't it
something like 20 there's 20 vacant
homes for every homeless person in this
country some crazy [ __ ] like that yeah
yeah okay it's like it's something it's
read that wild
which you know i want to check this you
don't think it's true 20 what do you
think it is that sounds about right 19.
okay
i think it's your price is writing him
but yeah i mean it's like crazy it's
like all about profit and greed and once
you start up down that road
for you're like doing it to preserve
your family but then once everyone
starts doing it then you start doing
some real stuff that's like self-harming
and self-destructive
and uh it's just like a bad track that
we're on and we just gotta fix it before
we die
as a species and it's easy to fix it's
just like you know humans are so
creative that they're even creative at
like doing the wrong thing right like
well i think we're going to fix i think
that i think the overall
game plan
with global warming is to just let
millions of people die
and then actually work towards fixing a
problem
that is efficient it
is it feels like that's the game plan
yeah right and like whatever minerals
like like whatever minerals we need to
create those things like the the wind
turbines and like the all the energy all
the resources will just wait for the
people in those countries to die and
then go in and then
farm the resources for everyone who
survives how long do you think uh like
if you estimate the time frame on
when that happens i don't know well
right now where every day in june in
texas right now is over 100 degrees yeah
yeah which it's usually in august or
like oh no it's gonna be that's hitting
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] yeah i think um
i i mean i think at least within the
next 10 years we're gonna see mass
migration in these like places that
become too hot like india and the middle
east
like i i don't know i think we live in a
part of a country where i think we might
be the lucky ones that survive
is it because if you if you need like
let's say you need like three billion
people to die before like maybe
temperatures start stabilizing well most
of them are going to come from asia
we got a lot yeah yeah so we got a lot
of people i mean if if
okay let's say let's see this let's say
i'm in the manager of like what's the
efficient way of cooling it down without
losing profits is to have a lot of
people die
people not murder people directly yeah
just let them die passive aggressively
let them die yeah yeah yeah so it's like
yeah uh yeah you uh
you just keep that's why i think that's
why these climates how would you pass
them really aggressively murder these
people i mean just continue the course
for the next couple years until they die
okay i think that seems to be the plan
yeah yeah that's that's what sony
thought about whitney houston and
michael jackson passing away they're
worth more dead in the live well i get
what you're saying
because they own sony well if it's all
about profit then it doesn't matter how
many lives are destroyed but if we
decide to be like hey let's take care of
lives then we can have a more humane
more efficient system
i don't think it's efficient to have a
bunch of people dying because the human
misery that causes
if it's not to limit that then what is
the point of all this like if we go to
space and all that and we just have to
suffer for millennia and
like this stupid facility
based on being alive just in general
just suffering yeah
isn't it isn't there isn't it isn't it
isn't it just always suffering like
everything you don't have to like make
it worse like there's plenty we can make
it like scandinavia you know you don't
like people you don't like picking at
the scab grow up in the ghettos just to
create just let's call it you're gonna
suffer anyways
he has his own problems i think well i
think and then a big part of those are
way preferable to our problems
yeah it's still like just not accepting
any foreigners and not accepting yeah
they're super homogeneous it's not like
that's so easy for one
not diverse group to be like everybody's
like
yeah can we do some of their policies
that they do for homogeneous people for
a very diverse place no but maybe work
there's a there is a big group of people
that were going to be like here in this
country that'd be like well i don't want
those people to get health care right
but isn't it possible to overcome that
urge well it doesn't seem that hard you
wouldn't you would need the people in
power to overcome marriage you would
need you would need you honestly i mean
i'll say you could do you wouldn't even
you would need white people to be like
oh okay yeah let's overcome the error
they have to because the the alternative
is the alternative way worse they create
these like the patriot front and the
proud boys and they do everything they
can to hold on to that power and that's
that's not efficient and it's better for
them if black people aren't starving and
robbing them all no no no no no
killing the game bro it's like a rotting
foot on your country it's better to have
help happy healthy black people than
like starving crazy they have enough of
them that they can make when i say them
i mean but if i was a person power
talking like that even if black people
were like or mexican people were like
donkeys you wouldn't want to have
donkeys that are starving running around
trying to get food you wanted happy
healthy donkeys so like donkeys but they
never they can never take over my regime
even if they're healthy though yeah you
would you would you
the really the i mean you're asking the
people in power to
let some of their power go and that's
just not gonna happen well like it
should it has to not without force yeah
well they should be whereas what is so
hard that's not always the case i mean
look at scandinavia or look at japan the
people there gave up their power yeah
no not always
there's like two atomic bombs not not
america versus japan japan versus japan
like upper class versus middle class
that was it like you're just used to
there's so many different ways for
people to be this way is just one of
them but like just being greedy shitty
[ __ ] isn't the norm i mean japan
before before that was like it was just
all people
it was a it was they were
assassination what i'm saying is there
are good parts of it i'm saying that
like it doesn't always have to be bad
i'm saying i don't know i don't think
and i don't think
people give up power willingly ever
that's what i'm saying i don't think
that ever happens i think soviet union
did after the cold war
they gave up their power willingly they
didn't nuke everybody you know
obama did no but i mean after his eight
years it i mean it
but
before that there were still several
proxy wars you know what i mean like
like there's bad stuff and there's good
stuff we should try to aim for the good
stuff it's not easy but it's the only
way forward i remember in dallas during
a uh during all the black lives matter
uh protests
they set up they set up their own
protest on the bridge of the march
margaret
bridge
anyways the cops actually is the one
that set that up so they can block both
sides and took everyone to jail
everyone that was on that bridge took
him to jail
but of course they couldn't they had
nothing on them but they just made it
seem like okay you got your protest we
locked y'all up now we're letting you
out and go home and there was another
never another protest after that
yeah but they the one that set up the
location they the one that put it out
there
and locked everyone up because they set
up a curfew so they can lock people up
yeah that's [ __ ] up they're afraid of
a speech
yeah i mean yeah and then that's like i
mean i mean you just see it with the way
our government runs now these [ __ ] 80
year olds refuse to get out of office
our our next presidential election
pelosi would well next presidential
election is going to be between as of
right now it looks like a 78 year old
and an 82 year old nice i'm rooting for
the 78 euros no that's the problem is
that you're rooting for either one of
them they both it's for the country to
be any sort of good
the best thing for the for the country
is that they both killed themselves yeah
that's the best thing for the country we
can't have a 78 year old but that's so
that's what we're doing we're having an
old sort of programming system for the
country it's like this is such a shitty
old system that is
one of the factors of a dying empire is
a gerundocracy right yeah but we're in
we're in the stages we've got to
progress we have all this technology and
knowledge and instead we're clinging
more to the past with the conservatives
yeah but people are [ __ ] idiots
there's a lot of [ __ ] idiots out
there
like they don't know how to learn they
don't even know how to put the first
step forward they were created like that
on purpose so they're easier to control
they're definitely easier to manipulate
sure
there's a reason why i mean they're
defunding public schools in texas
there's they just they want the people
to be dumb
that is for a hundred percent yeah it's
easier to make them conspiracy theory
minded and quiet
he lives in uh el paso and he said the
in school they taught them they had
agrito competitions
so food
just saying that yeah i wanted to learn
the education of it like why were they
teaching these kids
to grito but
that's in that area and you know it's by
the border so it's like what's that mean
grito yeah it's like a scream that is
you know what mets can do when they get
excited like that
yeah yeah they were teaching these kids
in the school this well
so i mean good grito is impressive
though
i don't know what
yeah man
people are [ __ ] idiots
yeah i mean especially people have so
much potential and we [ __ ] waste it
there was a way that someone can
if someone even was allowed to bring
people together to kind of fight the
system that person that even attempts
that there's so many ways that the power
is going to come at them and shut this
[ __ ] down yeah
you know or even try to create something
so what do you think about the austin
comedy scene
what a great scene huh there's so much
happening
the open mics are terrible
yes where do you go in dallas chicken
coop
i mean there's some decent ones there's
also some terrible ones
there's just so many comics and stuff
and i like that they're all close
together but yeah that's cool seeing
people passing by i do like that aspect
so it's better in dallas
no
i don't know it's a universal thing
there's more there's definitely a lot
more mics here yeah yeah but the way but
sometimes they're bar mics and stuff the
way people sign up it's it's a little i
don't i don't see it how you're taking
care of the comic that shows up early
you know it's like uh like
at one of the marks that i went to
everyone was waiting for the guy to get
there with the list
and then when he showed up with his
paper in his hand he everywhere he
walked they were following him waiting
for him to put it down somewhere was the
guy like lording it over he enjoyed it i
don't know if he sounds like some weird
sexual thing he did it on purpose but
he's like he's getting off i walk one
way and the whole thing is crowded and
so when he's trying to walk back
hey
it was pretty [ __ ] up huh was it
incompetence or evil
i think with confidence i think that's
what yeah the best way to do it is
randomize it that way you don't have
like a competition to see who can waste
the most time by showing up early
yeah and you don't have any favoritism
right just randomize it and like should
people show it five minutes before you
don't have to go there and you know have
30 minutes of prayer time before you do
your stage
comics
for a business aspect for whoever's
running the mic i mean i guess they they
allow the mic to happen because they
expect to make drinks off these people
or whatever but if you show up early and
the list is you know what time the list
goes out and you show up early then yeah
you should be able to put your name
wherever the [ __ ] you want
you know just who that's the more of a
little grind thing that i it should be
like if whoever shows up first gets to
go up first
go up wherever they want like uh yeah
it's it's like a haphazardly run and
nobody i would even try i would hate to
be an open micro in austin why just
starting from nothing just the amount of
like i don't even know where that the
pathway technically it would have to be
like this that killed tony or some [ __ ]
right now in terms of higher career
stuff
right now the pathway is just it's just
right because it's everything's waiting
for the club to open yeah sure true so
it's like there there is no there is a
because there is no club there is this
weird like sort of lack of hierarchy in
this scene and everyone just does
whatever they want like this guy
prancing around with the mic like
because
there is no source of actual power they
can have they can exert their you know
they can be acting like all-powerful and
stuff so yeah i get why i get why you
would be like yeah this would be this is
just austin right now such an
interesting place yes it is interesting
once the once the club opens then you
get to see what the scene actually is
yeah but right now it's just sort of
it's an under construction scene yeah
that's what it feels like the scene is
under it's better than most cities i
would say it's much better unless it is
yeah yeah
this is the gold gold rush of people who
are entertaining so happy people here
are partying yeah and having fun mm-hmm
yeah i mean
every monday and people who are making
like career strides yeah true i mean
hans is a good example uh eric is on the
road with andrew schultz i mean i've
noticed a lot more feature dates than i
would have in l.a you guys didn't start
yeah stage time here is just better
right oh yeah yeah yeah for the shows
yeah and the audiences are so much
better than la or new york because
they're not cynical
yeah
but uh yeah uh they're
it's like liberal people with like
conservative sensibilities almost yeah
like so it's like they're they're down
to hear everything and but they're also
open to what they're also open to what
you're saying they're open to who you
are and they're down to hear everything
it's both those things it's a nice
balance like it's it's like i'm sure it
changes from audience audience right now
yeah it changes but it's like it's this
is why i like it because it's like we're
not going to get turned off
because of maybe like words you use or
like you said that you quote unquote
said the wrong thing but we're also
listening to who you are actually so
we're not we're not we're not like
turned off to your personality yeah just
imagine that like a la audience member
like crossing their arms because you
know they're filthy rich they're at a
comic show they cross their arms and you
know i don't like that joke or they
speak up in texas if they're from l.a
and they come to texas and do that [ __ ]
here they're going to get called out for
it yeah it's like why are you a [ __ ]
being a grumpy person yeah it's like
weird
what are they saying oh just i just take
a look at the chat every once in a while
it's it's nice it's i just it's so nice
of the people it's so cool that people
are just chatting
i think that all the time
um but yeah i mean i think it's a great
scene i think it's like
good to be outside of the influence of
l.a or new york because those places are
entrenched with like people have been
there for so long and they've like
worked their way in and made it
those two cities for sure you got to pay
to perform them i think that's going to
ever happen here payback eventually uh
there's going to be a lot more new
comics that don't know and they're going
to pay and they're well it's it's you're
gonna find people who are like they're
they're like dream snatch like they feed
off people they're dream parasites
like you know like let me hear these
people with dreams let me just suck [ __ ]
out of them but the population is so
small here now now yeah how much can it
grow
but pretty it can grow a lot
not with the current way the city is
shaped
no the city is just going to expand and
figure out a new thing there's going to
be different parts of it it's going to
be like la i think we need more roads
that's what we need l.a it's going to be
like a railroad it's going to be like la
where it's like oh well i live on this
side of austin so i never see anyone who
lives on that side off sure like you
live in north hollywood how you're never
in santa monica there's the it's gonna
be like that there's a speed train on a
uh
built right now from dallas to austin to
houston where it'll take 30 minutes on
that train to get from dallas to austin
oh that'd be good it's under
construction right now that would be
dope
it's uh under the house
you know how americans do with trains
they're not very good at it no because
then because then the car companies will
be like this is [ __ ] at some point
the car companies will be like this is
[ __ ]
the flight the the airlines too well the
thing is like in most european or
chinese cities like you use a train then
you're in the country the city that you
want to be in and then you can take the
public transit everywhere but if you're
in dallas without a car
i'm in dallas without a car it is
[ __ ] yeah crazy you'd have to rent
the car take an uber everywhere yeah you
need something extra but if you take the
train in dallas it takes forever to get
yeah b now
right yeah no they did a good job and
they did it on purpose to make sure to
make sure public transportation wasn't
good here just so you had to buy a car
and public transportation is the much
better way to move around always every
time i've been to a place where i don't
need a car i'm like this is way better
yeah i mean when i was taking the dart
the other day i saw someone literally
smoke meth on the dart train so that's a
little a little bit like new york now
it's getting a little
it's getting a little seedy well if you
have no public transportation that guy's
still doing meth you just can't see him
doing it i prefer that
do we have to get out of here
no
um
it's just like
i think riley's watching yeah that's bad
oh
oh man
that's so funny
[Laughter]
hey
he's doing a podcast tony can you keep
it down over there yeah god you're so
[ __ ] loud
i'm sorry my friend
you want to grab a mic
sure
all right is there anything to grab even
stairs
you gotta work what is that oh that's
the airflow that's the air filter oh
sodas
well yeah i mean
what's
i mean i guess they hate me anyways yeah
well yeah i mean i didn't know i didn't
find out he's definitely texting me oh
he was like i can't believe you're
talking about this on the podcast yeah
yeah welcome to the green room podcast
baby i guess
that's so funny that's so funny just
another bag of worm
yeah that you get to deal with
yeah are you gonna mean this
apology i don't know
i felt like that was pretty fair
but
what uh what do you think about the
whole uh you know
kind of casino situation
i mean he could stand to lose a couple
pounds but other than that
i think it's going pretty good
i like this weird accent that you
you take on
this is there's a character
uh armenian armenian armenian okay
yeah come on my friend that's a good
vibe that's a good vibe
yeah buddy only for you yes but you're
at times price you get two you save you
save more money you're italian though
right
someone thought you were mexican
your last name
is my grandpa was adopted
like three course german and of course
were they like argentinian
the hispanic okay no mexican okay just
the nazis
little house
mm-hmm
[Music]
all right
[Laughter]
now on the topic ai the ai coming to
life okay where did that last oh did we
talk we did talk about that last week
we'll talk about trans athletes again
exactly he looks like a transit
he does
he does he doesn't look like an athlete
at all
looks like a trans couch potato
oh yeah i mean have we seen i've
actually never seen a trans athlete
compete all i hear is news stories about
them yeah but it sounds like they're
killing it
yeah yeah i mean like if i wanted like
okay
if i didn't tell anybody and somehow i
decided you know i'm gonna be a woman
now like i can do that how much should
we get along with your delusion you
don't think i can get away with it
sometimes you have to be like okay yeah
you can call yourself karen of course i
have to call you karen but then like
where does it end
i think never ends the same as trying to
if i'm better as a woman i'm gonna stay
a woman so they can sign up for the
women's sports i feel like that's the
worst thing it's a women's sports
just women's sports in general but if
that's the worst thing trans people are
gonna do then it's not that big a deal i
mean i don't think i don't have a
problem with them competing but like i
guess the genetics is all it's like it's
it's not fair right like the
the you know the estrogen and the
testosterone like that
that's not fair game yeah and people are
like oh they're going to go into schools
and teachers like these weirdos that you
know couldn't get late are going to tell
everyone about their pee-pees and
poo-poos yeah that's not about trans
people this is about like the weirdo
freaks that we have that are trying i
understand why they put that in schools
anyway to teach that because that's
something your parents need to teach
teach schools i don't feel like i'm
teaching some it's well sometimes they
were in florida but they banned teachers
from teaching it anymore they were
teaching but this is this is what are
they teaching or were they saying that
they were teaching it that's the thing
it's like how much of them was actually
teaching it how much of them was wrong
one story and then blowing it out of
proportion what i don't like about the
florida build that i read was that a
teacher a parent can determine whether
or not a teacher overset the boundaries
which is insane
i mean i remember my kid came from
school singing r kelly and i was like
and i started singing along with him and
then i was like how do you know that
song he was like how do you know that
song
his teacher taught them because they
were teaching them about muhammad ali
i'm the world's greatest i thought they
were teaching them about potty training
or something
yeah hold your kids he's uh 12 and 13 12
13 what they're teaching muhammad ali
well teaching them our kelly song
because they were teaching them about
muhammad ali the world's greatest by our
kev yeah yeah i know it's like i didn't
know they were teaching 11 year olds
about muhammad ali
yeah that seems yeah that seems crazy in
and of itself
yeah well they were like i guess it was
like black history month oh yeah that
makes sense
of course it was in february
it's the only time the only month they
had well i feel like education since we
were kids has changed to be more
internet based and how we learn on the
internet like back in the day we just
learned from textbooks and learning was
very rigid and formal but now it's sort
of like yeah muhammad ali and r kelly
and all that it's like
there's more you know
like
current and relevant you know what's
interesting the way you guys i mean like
i'm i'm in the [ __ ] idiot i'm hanging
a lot of you but yeah i can agree i can
i can i can hear you
like how can you teach if you ever had
kids how can you teach what you just
said that idea to your kids without them
not getting [ __ ] up at school muhammad
ali
no no no i'm talking about like the the
way you see the world like the way the
way like liberal propaganda yeah is that
how you see the world how would you see
the real problem i would teach your kids
that would you teach your kids that or
will you stay stay on that same mindset
if you had a kid
um yeah i would teach them that this is
not an ideal way to build a city and if
you build a city some other way then
it's better what's up kids
how do you think they would like uh like
handle that when they when they were on
the they're on their own
they'd be like oh hey uh
i can live in a different country where
i can walk around instead of living on
in this suburban sprawl [ __ ] where i
can't even
walk anywhere the nearest store is like
three miles away yeah that sucks that
does that doesn't yeah yeah yeah
and you can't even walk it's like a
[ __ ] crazy thing
so do you think city should be up and
out
uh it's just like europe five stories
smacks
it's like you don't have to like make it
like skyscrapers like no city to
skyscrapers that's just too much
uh yeah five stories is the max really
but uh yeah what do you think about the
whole [ __ ] you know
this whole
austin scene and like how we have
parties every night and
i think what's the coolest part of
austin you think why do you always come
here
i i like well i used to come here a long
time ago i used to play basketball and
the party on 6th street that was like a
regular thing but now i can't even stay
on the street for too long unless it has
to do with comedy
i only come here only for comedy nothing
for not not like to party
at a club where i can see poverty
replace basketball yeah comedy replace
basketball
nice i mean it's a more sustainable
thing and it's more rewarding
yeah i usually use basketball i like to
let go of all that [ __ ] frustration
working nine to five and [ __ ] just
basketball is my thing
and it gets a little touchy but i guess
so does comedy
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh god same thing with me but mine was
heroin
so
yeah now you're doing one-liners instead
of no i'll do bits i do chunks
lines of coke
yeah austin i mean i knew being from
dallas how the what changed in austin
because they people that used to live
here before the boom happen they would
tell you like it would be super
politically correct like if you even
went up with certain ideas that was not
like that you would get you know
yeah it was a click
it was a great scene
yeah before it was a great scene that uh
it was
that's why joe rogan moved here sort of
but um yeah i came here before and you
know every city was like that before the
pandemic
i feel like the pandemic made people a
little more
uh gave up on [ __ ] they used to care
about something like that
like the [ __ ] the it's harder it was
harder for the [ __ ] to get through
because it was like we're not willing to
buy the [ __ ] when things are so
shitty
in the house and yeah you can you're
more willing to buy the [ __ ] if things
are going okay but if like you want me
to buy into a failing system it's like
why yeah priorities why evaluating
priorities
well you want to be on the winning side
it doesn't seem like the side is winning
right that's so true yeah hey but do you
think uh the the protest in hong kong
had anything to do with coronavirus no
because that was like the longest
protest they ever had in that
in that country
it was for two months straight i think
even if they did that on purpose like it
probably wouldn't have worked
right it was overkill it was still a
mistake like it still got out
and destroyed the whole world and made
china look real there's a lot of things
that happened right
i mean like i remember the nba coach
from houston to tweet it out we stand
with the we stand with hong kong or
something like that and then boom china
just cut nba out sponsors games in china
they just cut them out completely
because they want to eat oh there's
something interesting that's
authoritarian government's going to
figure out coming up is
everything is so intercollected globally
like
as much as china wants to cut out people
that say maybe anti-chinese things they
do still rely on america for so much of
their money
and like we still rely on china for so
much of our stuff as we move towards
what looks like looks like we're moving
some kind of authoritarian direction it
just feels that way um so it'll be it'll
be interesting to see like how the how
like these interconnected like regimes
will deal with each other because it
wasn't that way in the past right you
could be this sort of insulated place
but now the world is too much do you
think this is ukraine russia thing is
going to lead to something more more
major i mean i think that it already
exposed russia's not being as powerful
as a military power as we thought i
think it already exposed russia's weak
and if russia is weak
that means you know
it's a whole thing because russia
for so many years and has been this
strong country and i like okay they
can't even take over ukraine territory
that was theirs at one point yeah so now
we live in a world with a weak russia
that's that's interesting yeah that's
different i don't know what that means
but it means
could that be
us propaganda like maybe
no russia should steamroll them
okay but there's also like it's just
like britain should steamrolled america
but then france and that was and that
was
we're a dying empire that's interesting
so russia ussr
became no more and they didn't nuke
everyone they were like [ __ ] it
[ __ ] you right if america did the same
thing you do think that if we were dying
we'd be like [ __ ] everybody
actually i was gonna say i was like i
don't think anyone would push the button
but i think
trump
might trump has that in him
he's the look what he did when he lost
the election yeah yeah imagine if he
lost the country yeah yeah
he is he is the reason
he is the child of multi-millionaires a
spoiled child of multi-millionaires and
those are generally the worst people
yeah
sure
i think he's just a character that the
people in this country use to express
their most based desires
he's just a puppet he's just like a
figurehead that they put in like yeah
this is our guy now i can do whatever i
actually wanted to do
yeah
but uh yeah i mean that's why i don't
give a [ __ ] about what the left does
they're trying to squirt hormones into
my kids i don't give a [ __ ] if my kid's
stupid enough to have that done to him
that's his fault like the what stuff
that the right is doing is so much worse
black people starving in the streets
like i don't care about transgender i
don't care about you know that's not a
big deal to me
like but black people like you know
begging for change and like robbing
people like that could be solved and
it's not going to get solved by being
more mean to them right no yeah
we should give them money instead of
being like work harder like that's so
you saying that
us giving us giving ukraine
aid all that money we should have took
care of here first well yeah you should
always take care of our infrastructure
is failing there's so many places that's
the right idea though there's so many
places without clean water idea that's
the right idea that's there's so many
places in this country without clean
water but they're just never gonna yeah
they're never gonna fix that a budget
shortfall is built into your pay so they
want you to be poor yeah okay we're
always going to be in debt we're never
going to come out of debt yeah because
if we're out of debt then you can do
more for the community yeah we just have
to let money flow more instead of
trapping up top but
i just want to give more money to the
poor i think that would be the biggest
thing
but whatever you know who knows it's
like
economical it's not really my area of
expertise
well well i do one thing that i can say
for sure about economics is that this
trickle-down [ __ ] isn't working
no no that's very clear so it's like
that's why i mean maybe the plane is
giving way to the poor yeah you don't
get rich by letting money trickle away
from you yeah or trickle down you and
like letting it all just be hoarded up
there by the same couple the rich are
very good at not letting things trickle
yes
yeah
they're not good tricklers
trickling or tricking jews to trickling
uh anyways you want to call it
yeah they're playing music i think
they're about to open the doors right
doors are already open all right see you
guys see ya